all right we got a whole bunch of stuff
that we got to go over let's start with
uh first just a general sentiment check
how are you feeling about the bitcoin
market where we are coming into the end
of the year has anything changed
nothing's changed um i mean i think the
timeline is a little bit delayed like
compared to what a lot of people thought
in the fall at the beginning of q4 um
you know a lot of people were kind of
expecting to see to see higher prices
than than today and for you know
all-time highs to be excuse me for
all-time highs to continue to be to be
made here but in terms of the thesis in
terms of what bitcoin is and and you
know where we're going with this whole
thing nothing has changed i think you
know that's what we're going to dig into
a little bit today
all right so
when we start looking at some of the
charts that we have here the first that
we're gonna pull up is this bitcoin
store value medium exchange or unit of
account and you just have uh what looks
like the price
pulled up in terms of uh
uh over the years what exactly are you
showing here
yeah so this is more of just like a kind
of a title slide i saw some some of the
jack discourse last night um in the next
slide it kind of it was a question that
says do you think the that bitcoin will
replace the us dollar um and you know
there's definitely a lot of debate
bitcoin is digital gold or bitcoin is
going to displace a dollar or bitcoin uh
to some people is a ponzi scheme um but
really i think uh you know we're going
to use some some metrics today and look
at some charts and kind of break down
what what i believe and i think what a
lot of people
that are bitcoin proponents believe is
that bitcoin is actively becoming or is
already all three um and then the data
kind of shows that
all right so if we start with uh the
first chart we've got the issuance rate
and the circulating supply and market
cap all overlaid on each other what
exactly is this showing
yeah so this is kind of supporting the
store value argument right so you hear a
lot of people um increasingly over the
last couple years this has been an
accepted kind of proposition bitcoin is
digital gold it's a digital store of
value
and while that was controversial for a
long time
a lot of the skeptics um you know
besides a few have come to accept that
you know bitcoin is a store of value and
you know in the 21st century um
especially after the kind of covid
madness and all of the trillions of
dollars of stimulus bitcoin is a store
of value and so you know it's the one
thing we know that it has a hard cap is
absolutely scarce in the world uh this
issuance rate or inflation rate
is programmatically trending to towards
zero over time
the blue line that's actually in log
scale so
in linear and linear scale it looks like
the issuance rate is already basically
at zero
and the market the market cap is is
really just a testament of people around
the world allocating you know resources
and capital to this asset class because
of its monetary assurances and so the
store value argument is stronger than
ever
but you know i don't think it stops
there and that's when uh you know the
discourse gets a little more interesting
got it and so really what this is
showing is as that issuance rate goes
down or some people could think that it
almost has like an inflation rate uh the
circulating supply goes up right uh
because we're getting more and more
bitcoin just at a slower pace uh but the
market cap has continued to grow at the
exact same time as well which ends up
being uh a kind of a what you would
expect if you've got a finite supply
asset with a disinflationary monetary
supply schedule uh an increasing demand
is you're going to continue to get the
price to go up even though there's a
little bit of bitcoin still coming into
the market uh the demand outpaces that
and that's where you get market cap
growth right
yeah exactly i mean it's pretty simple
it's how many dollars are going to exist
in 2030 or in 2100 right no one knows no
one knows really for any other asset
except bitcoin and and you know this
because you can run a full node on you
know an old laptop or you can verify the
supply on your smartphone and there's no
other technology yes there are other
crypto assets that are somewhat
transparent but the thing is that none
of the monetary policies of these other
assets or you know digital uh assets are
basically as uh tried and tested as
bitcoin and no one can change bitcoin um
and every protocol change that has
occurred has been um opt-in voluntary
it's a soft fork
there's no hard forks or changes to the
monetary policy of bitcoin you know
whereas other crypto protocols or assets
um or currencies if you want to call
them that have have done that plenty of
time so in terms of in terms of absolute
scarcity nothing in the world um has or
can compete with bitcoin
the next thing we've got is the hash
rate 70x since 2017 which is the bonkers
number uh
explain why you think this is so
important
yeah so this is kind of um on the store
value side of things as well 70x in the
last five years um just kind of
understanding what that means what hash
rate actually means you can you know for
for people that are more kind of visual
and don't really understand what bitcoin
mining is
think of the you know gold miners going
in with with shovels and excavators and
digging into the earth to find this
monetary asset well think about if if
that had decreased 70-fold over the last
five years just the amount of
expenditure and the amount of resources
that are going into actually extracting
you know that that shiny rock out of the
earth well bitcoin is that but in the
digital form and it's doing it all over
the world um with sometimes nothing
other than just a satellite signal and a
wasted energy source
where there is no economic value
and it's basically securing and being
rewarded uh it's securing the most
powerful computer network in the world
it's being it's they're being rewarded
with the only absolutely scarce monetary
asset and so incentives are aligned
that's all bitcoin is is just economic
incentives it's completely voluntary
it's opt-in
and hashrate continues to grow at a just
mind-boggling exponential pace
when we think about
the entire network hash rate in 2013
that is equivalent to one s19j pro is
that true
yeah so the s19 jpro it's top of the
line uh you know new asic
but that basically spins off 110
terahash a day i think it costs around
fifteen thousand dollars maybe twenty
thousand it's it's extremely hard to get
miners with all the kind of supply
chains backed up and they're back
ordered from you know months or years
but yeah one asic one one new
top-of-the-line asic is equivalent to
the entire network hash rate in 2013. um
and so it just kind of shows you
moore's laws in play there with kind of
semiconductors becoming more and more
efficient but that just shows you just
like the just absolutely insane growth
and just amount of
physical capital um and resources you
know backing this network uh there is
definitely a tangible aspect to it
despite it being you know uh thin air or
you know
what a lot of people like to call it
yeah it's pretty incredible uh when we
look at the next chart we've got bitcoin
is on pace to settle 45 trillion in 2021
totaling twice as much value as all of
his previous years combined
that is an insane number
yeah so this is a chart from you seeing
that at arcs they put out great stuff
um and this is just kind of this is
going into more of the medium of
exchange aspect of it right so everyone
gets store value you can buy bitcoin you
can you can leave it on coinbase or you
can send it to your cold storage and you
can sit sit there and watch it and and
it's a pretty strong bet over time that
it'll increase your purchasing power um
just due to the absolute scarcity of it
and due to the adoption curve and more
and more people coming to this asset
class because of those properties right
but most people um or you know less than
the amount of people that understand the
story value side
don't really you know the the medium of
exchange or maybe the settlement aspect
of bitcoin is very underappreciated so
this network in a completely apolitical
sovereign way where there's there's no
ceo there's no board there's no uh
there's really there's no off switch
right china just picked up and you know
50 of the network was forced to to shut
off overnight uh and bitcoin kept on
chugging right so you know 45 trillion
dollars or on pace for that in 2021 um
it's a pretty insane number and so uh
you know you're competing you're
doubling or i'm sorry yeah doubling visa
i believe uh and and that's you know
pretty different when you're looking at
settlement assurances but say the best
comparison is fedwire well that's you
know we're already six percent of the
way there compared to fedwire and so i
wouldn't bet on this trend uh stopping
anytime soon uh and you know that kind
of supports the more medium of exchange
aspect to it there's you know final
settlement all over the world 24 7 365.
yeah it's pretty incredible uh bitcoin
the cumulative network transfer volume
22.2 uh
22.6 trillion as of 1221 uh which is uh
today
yeah so that's the first chart show just
total volume and this one um i should
have labeled it a little better shows
change adjusted transfer volume so the
bitcoin utxo set when say you have one
bitcoin and you send 0.5
well i send point five to you pomp and
point five bitcoin goes back to me and
that's a that's a change that's uh you
like change for the utxo and so
technically change adjusted volume just
filters out that 0.5 bitcoin i sent back
to to myself um just that's how bitcoin
transactions work um and so over the
course of its history um bitcoin is has
done 22.6 trillion dollars of change
justice volume um and that's you know
obviously hockey sticking up and to the
right and so i just kind of shows you
that you know this protocol is
continuing to grow and in terms of
medium exchange it's a lot bigger and
does a lot more value than people think
which means that bitcoin in 2021 has
done over 10 trillion right so you know
about 10 to 12 trillion of this about
half of it was done this year in 2021
compared to what it's done since its
beginning of its life
yeah correct it's pretty insane yeah
absolutely nuts and and uh i don't know
the exact visa uh settlement number but
i do believe that uh visa's annual
transaction volume
is now
right around what bitcoins is like
they're they're much closer than you
would think right i think that visa if i
remember correctly is somewhere in the
like 14 to 16 uh
trillion number and obviously bitcoin
being at let's call it 12 or so uh
hasn't quite eclipsed it yet but uh but
we're getting pretty damn close
yeah and i think a lot of people it
should be to be said that you know
comparing visa to bitcoin it's
definitely um a cool kind of comparison
and a milestone but just in terms of
settlement assurances and final and you
know just yeah settlement finality um
it's a lot different right swiping my
car to visa basically they have an
internal ledger and they just they just
debit someone and basically just change
the ledger a little bit but it can be
changed uh pretty easily there's there's
no final settlement for sometimes you
know weeks or months on end and at the
end of at the end of whatever period
that is the bank and and visa will you
know transfer over you know billions of
dollars and kind of that's the final
settlement but when people are comparing
you say a 10-minute bitcoin transaction
or bitcoin blocks to visa it's
definitely the wrong comparison i think
that next this next trip that we'll show
is more apples to apples
all right now we've got the lightning
network public channel capacity
yeah so this is in in usd uh and it's in
logarithmic scale so uh the growth is a
lot more impressive if you're looking at
it in linear terms but this is public
channel lightning network capacity so
back in 2017 back when there was the
scaling wars um bitcoin can't scale was
the narrative um the solutions were
bitcoin cash or other altcoins um the
payments narrative despite not being
done today was was pretty big back then
and there's a lot of questions about how
could bitcoin ever be this you know as
some proponents would say world reserve
currency if if it could only do you know
seven transactions per second which is
completely the wrong way to look at it
um so here comes the lightning network
um and with the segwit soft fork in 2017
um there was some upgrades that could
allow for light the lightning network to
be built which was just a concept
conceived in 2016. um so since then um
you basically have um
this lightning network which is just a
an application layer or a software layer
above the bitcoin network and it's
completely it's completely open source
um it's completely opt-in and and
basically it allows for bitcoin payments
to occur um
somewhat instantaneously and for
basically no cost or little to no cost
and so we've seen that that growth is
exponential and you're seeing a lot of
companies like strike and open node and
companies all over the world just
basically opt in to this um open for
basic not free but uh you know voluntary
settlement layer uh on top of bitcoin
and so this allows for micro payments
this allows i can send you one satoshi
pop and so that's something that was
never possible with with bitcoin on the
base layer um and it's just this is
basically how bitcoin will scale to
billions and billions of people and it's
it's not appreciated nearly enough i
completely agree bitcoin price drawdown
from all-time high when you see this all
of a sudden maybe uh maybe we shouldn't
be complaining so much because uh there
are some epic epic drawdowns over the
years but uh what is this showing
yeah so we we covered store value we
covered medium of exchange
what's the last one unit of account um
so how could bitcoin ever be a unit of
account if it's if it's this volatile um
so
obviously we're looking at a logarithmic
scale of bitcoin in the background there
and the red is showing the drawdowns
from all time high so really kind of
what this is pointing at is you know the
volatility is the price you pay for
returns and when when something is
growing in exponential fashion um you
will see a very standard double-digit
you know 20 30 40 50 drawdowns along the
way um and that's just basically more
opportunity to accumulate uh and to you
know just to get your hands on this
pristine absolutely scarce asset so
currently you know 31 down from all
highs uh for anyone that's been in
bitcoin for more than a couple months
even it's it's really nothing uh and
it's it's an opportunity to just
continue to stack so you know just some
context and and the next few charts here
will break down why bitcoin as a unit of
account is uh quite superior
all right now we've got s p 500
uh
as just the first chart uh let's just do
the uh the actual price chart itself
so stocks only go up right or at least
that's what max uh
that's what uh has you know we've been
taught over the last 24 months or so but
why is that um and a lot of people think
they're getting rich just you know
especially asset holders um you know
that everything's going up and to the
right but in reality uh it's more of a
farce and or maybe a cade and actually
it's just the money is debasing so what
happens if we standardize s p 500 and we
put it in m2 money supply terms uh it
looks a lot different and so what we're
looking at since 2020 uh if you just if
you just standardize uh this chart in
terms of m2 money stock the s p 500 is
basically flat um and so a lot of people
that think they've gotten pretty rich
over the last 18 24 months
in reality it's just a function of
monetary expansion
and so
this kind of
leads you to believe that the dollar
over the short term while
i guess the fed or other you know kind
of public officials would call it stable
um it's actually a melting ice cube as
some would like to say and and if you're
valuing anything uh whether it's assets
goods services you know home prices
anything uh in big and in dollar terms
uh you're gonna you're gonna it's gonna
kind of skew you to believe that things
are getting more expensive when in
reality uh many things are getting less
expensive it's just the currency the
unit uh is devaluing um and so here we
have a solution which is bitcoin
got it and so when you divide it by this
m2 doesn't look so hot and my guess is
that if you actually went ahead and you
denominated this in bitcoin obviously it
would be down significantly uh which i
think is uh you're oh yeah it is your
next one of course you're two steps
ahead of me go ahead
yeah there's like little bread crumbs
right like you're just this is like a
little game go ahead
yeah so i mean volatility obviously is
there you see in march of 2020 that that
big green candle but over the long term
um bitcoin is
the best unit of account you can use
nothing else is absolutely scarce like
we've kind of covered and so
just denominating something as simple as
s p or even individual stocks uh in
bitcoin terms
will lead you to be one of the best uh
or most ahead of the game capital
allocators out there i think this is
kind of the strategy for savvy investors
over the next decade and it has been in
the last decade but increasingly i think
it will become the standard is
denominating your returns against
bitcoin
all right and then lastly you've got
micro strategy both against dollars and
bitcoin how are we looking
yeah so um talking about going on a
bitcoin standard valuing your your
company valuing you know your assets and
bitcoin terms here's microstrategy since
uh they've adopted a bitcoin standard up
282 percent um obviously some pretty
spectacular growth
uh
for a company that was was kind of
treading water for the last decade and
now if we denominate in bitcoin terms um
they're doing fantastic and they have
110 000 bitcoin
but their unit their their share price
in satoshi's their share price you know
in bitcoin terms
has basically surprisingly or maybe not
surprisingly been flat right so so they
have actually kept pace with the bitcoin
standard um and so few companies can say
the same um and i think this will become
kind of the way that you know uh savvy
investors and increasingly everybody
will have to value things uh in the 21st
century uh bitcoin is the most superior
unit of account uh and if you're valuing
things bitcoin yes there's there's
short-term volatility but over the long
term uh you're definitely ahead of the
game and you'll get a step on on people
who are not
how do you think about uh
bitcoin
when it starts to become less volatile
so obviously everything is kind of
crashing against bitcoin because
bitcoin's price is going up at a pretty
insane uh rate compared to us dollars
if bitcoin is to eventually reach
price stability in u.s dollar terms
which
may or may not happen but if that was to
occur how do you think about it then
being denominated all these other assets
yeah so i think if you look at a lot of
things there's a pretty fantastic chart
out there that i don't have on me at the
moment but it's over the last 20 years
the price of everything um
from like technology to education to
health care to consumer goods and you
know the university education and
basically everything that technology has
touched is is way down at the price of
the the price of a tv or a semiconductor
or just an iphone think about how much
an iphone gives you over the last 10
years well maybe the price has gone up
but the value is gone way way up so
actually technology um it's it's
deflationary in the sense that you get
more for less
and so when you when you don't have that
expanding you know
monetary unit the dollar expanding money
supply that's chasing everything that's
becoming more expensive over the last
decade or two um it's because more
dollars are chasing that university
education subsidized healthcare
subsidized all of these things that are
becoming way way more expensive is
because
essentially the government or you know
just the economy in general is chasing
an increasing amount of
throwing an increasing amount of dollars
at it and so that's why you see these
things becoming exponentially more
expensive over time
i i believe on a bitcoin standard on an
absolutely scarce monetary standard
global monetary standard
things will gradually uh decrease in in
price over time as the as the money
approves value basically as the world
becomes more productive uh your money
accrues value uh in everything else and
so i think that's what you know what the
future holds and it won't you won't see
these exponential gains that we see
over the last decade and i think over
the coming decade but uh you know i
think you could expect with human
productivity your purchasing power would
increase one to two to maybe five
percent a year depending uh on a bitcoin
standard and i think that's you know
that's pretty exciting
when you start to think about um how
well people understand this like what's
your take on the jack dorsey web 3
tweets versus uh
kind of the web 3 pro argument if you
will like what do you think
yeah i think um i i kind of agree with
jack here in the sense that i i'm all
for the free market and i'm all for you
know people going and building things
and trying things out 100
um but i think a lot of uh the
incentives are skewed and a lot of these
if you want to call it web3
uh applications or ecosystems um whether
it's you know with and and not that you
know investing is bad in general right
you know the argument for pre-mine is
well every stock or company is pre-mined
um and that's fair but uh you know if
we're talking about a company or a
security versus an open protocol i think
it's a lot you know a little bit
different or actually a lot different
and so you know bitcoin crypto kind of
gets all lumped into one uh and i think
it's it's quite different uh we covered
it a little bit last week the
differences between say bitcoin and
ethereum uh and i'm fine i'm all for the
free market i don't want regulators to
come in and clamp down on on these
builders or engineers um at all but i
think just in terms of
say an open internet and uh you know
so-called decentralization um a lot of
it's more decentralization theater and
that's fine i think just there's quite a
difference between say bitcoin uh versus
what a lot of these other tokens
protocols um web3 applications are doing
and that's fine right um but just you
know saying everything is going to be on
a blockchain or creator economy and
everyone's gonna have their own personal
token um i mean it's it's ambitious and
so we'll see what happens but you know i
think uh the biggest kind of idea in the
room uh is you know what jack thinks and
that's sound money for the world i think
that's that's the big idea here john
what questions you got yeah dylan thanks
for joining us um john so how have you
thought about the hash rate is this kind
of it's up what 70 since 2017 what do
you think it looks like moving forward
yeah um 70x since since 2017. i think
and i think it continues to just kind of
bend up into the right um it's it's hard
to see that that sort of exponential
growth as as we kind of get closer and
closer to um not the end of moore's law
but as moore's law kind of slows down a
little bit um i'm not i'm not calling an
end to uh the the efficiency of
semiconductors and computing power but
um you've started to see somewhat of a
commod commodification of the of asics
of bitcoin miners um an s9 has been
around for you know i think four or five
years and it's still spitting off a lot
of a lot of free cash flow a lot of
profit um and so you know i think the
new miners today you'll be able to plug
in for for quite a long time and for
them to to be quite profitable um you
know whereas say the mining rigs or you
know the usb sticks that you could plug
into your laptop from 2012 aren't going
to be profitable anymore you can't mine
bitcoin with gpus and be profitable
but i think a lot of these asics will be
around for a long time uh despite the
fact that bitcoin hash rate i would i
would think is gonna probably ten uh or
a hundred x over the coming decade um
just with you know the pure amount of
incentives that that will exist for for
people to you know plug these machines
in i think every energy producer is
going to get involved um and in a big
way but uh we're just starting to see
that play out how do you think about the
consumer like the retail consumer
getting involved in mining
versus that's pretty exciting
it's pretty exciting i think um we're
gonna see i i believe we're gonna see
especially in cold um cold regions or
climates um you know the rise of the
home miner um you know some very very
savvy kind of engineers or or bitcoiners
if you want to say i've been doing this
already but the reality is you know
these these miners kick off a lot of
excess heat um and so doing it uh
somewhere that's pretty cold is actually
you know you can kind of get a two for
one where you're you're mining bitcoin
and you're producing a lot of excess uh
energy and heat and that byproduct can
actually you know heat your home so it's
like almost two birds with one stone and
so um it's something that actually i'm i
am exploring currently uh but i think
we'll see that a lot and it'll kind of
just become i think square's working on
that right they're working on building
that out and in their uh in their app as
well as working on an asic so um that
would be pretty exciting and i think
we're a little bit away from kind of
that that becoming the standard but it
would be awesome to see uh in you know
coming five years or so i agree
what i also think would be really
interesting i don't think i've seen one
yet that seems viable and commercial
is when you start to get uh anything
that plugs into uh some sort of
electricity and it mines bitcoin in its
off hours so like i'll use the super
egregious
almost absurd example but like you could
see it happening
is somebody builds like a microwave when
it's plugged in
uh it's pulling a little bit of power
right because i was obviously able to
display the time and that type of stuff
but is there a world where the microwave
pays for itself by being able to mine
bitcoin even though it's got very little
computing power right so like that's the
agrees example like okay now walk it
back into well what happens if all of a
sudden you're able to take other things
like the tesla power wall may be a good
example right if they were essentially
able to say hey look we're going to use
renewable power that's stored in this
battery and we're going to take that and
then build kind of a mining component to
it you can actually hey when you're not
consuming the power if you don't uh if
you're running out or
of capacity or something just go ahead
and almost like burn it but you're
burning it by using it to drive some
sort of monetary value and help secure
the decentralized bitcoin network like
go ahead
it's pretty interesting i think bitcoin
mining kind of will will you know almost
like flatten out these um these
disparities and energy prices across the
world right you're seeing um you know
you're seeing a huge energy crisis in
europe right so uh bitcoin miners in
europe currently um they're they're
probably not gonna be um on full tilt
right they're gonna they're gonna
instead sell their their energy to the
grid right you're seeing a lot of like
you know grid miners that um like in
texas per se um that are that are
establishing this base load uh energy
demand and then when demand spikes they
turn off and so you can see that kind of
at a micro level right where say maybe
not a microwave but say a water heater
right so um a lot of these things are
you know continuing to
be built out and there's engineers all
over the world kind of working on this
stuff um bitcoin mining uh with
immersion cooling right it's kind of
like
these these ideas that are coming out of
nowhere um and they're you know they're
really fascinating and i i mean we're
just scratching the surface in terms of
what can be done uh with kind of this
this new found um demand or ability to
take energy from anywhere uh and and
turn it into sound money and so i think
the applications and the the you know
the engineering uh you know feats that
will be built on top of this and around
this network uh is something that i i
can't fathom and i'll let other people
figure that out
last question i have for you is going
into uh christmas you got any advice for
folks in terms of how they can help
orange peel their family
that's a good question um yeah i mean i
would just say uh everyone it you know
it takes time and everyone will kind of
come to bitcoin when they're ready but
just planting the seed about what sound
money and a low time preference does uh
is is important um kind of just you know
distincting bitcoin from a lot of you
know speculative investments and even
bitcoin itself on a shorter time frame
is speculative right so maybe showing
the the four year dca returns um which i
don't know off the top of my head but i
know they're they're pretty strong
and just kind of preaching a little time
preference maybe saying why is
everything getting more expensive in the
world uh whether it's housing or food or
energy or anything else right uh and and
kind of establishing that it's not a
result of greedy corporations as maybe
an elizabeth warren would say but it's
more so about an expanding money supply
uh and just kind of planting the seed
because uh ultimately everybody will
will need bitcoin everybody will own
bitcoin
and that may sound controversial today
but i think 10 years from now it won't
be at all and so just kind of you know
planting the seed with people that you
care about is is uh you know definitely
a good gift to give at least
for their future self
i i think that's a great way to uh to
end it uh if we do a quick follower
check
98.8 man we're about to cross 100k
this is i think well i think we were
talking what you were at 50k a couple of
weeks ago
yeah i think the first time i came on i
was a little bit under that and so
definitely
definitely uh getting close there
making moves john
yeah where you at i'm at right under 60
and dylan i just congratulations when
you
when you provide good content though
people um
people go to it so
that's how the world works all right i'm
gonna drop uh drop his twitter account
in here uh if you're not following dylan
get with the program let's go
gotta we got things we got to get done
so dylan thank you so much for uh for
doing this have a uh a merry christmas
happy holidays whatever the appropriate
thing to say these days is uh just enjoy
the time with your family um and then uh
i guess well next tuesday is the next
show that we'll do so dylan will be back
the next time that you guys see us
you'll see dylan which will be uh be
pretty good
sweet happy holidays guys thanks for
having me on all right buddy sounds good
thank you
catch you later